>>Lindsey: My body is so steady and
calm because your bodies are so steady.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: Being
able to teach children how
to manage their emotions is
actually a very important pathway
to intellectual learning.
Because if you can't manage
your feelings, it's hard to open
up your brain to be able to receive the
content that you're trying to learn.
>>Lindsey: I do a lot of
work around self-awareness,
being able to name emotions and
then make a choice around those.
You have a large range of
emotions during a school day,
working with children.
Some are completely joyful
and so exciting,
and some are really frustrating
or incredibly disheartening.
>>Lindsey: When you talk
when I'm talking,
it feels like you're not
ready to listen to me.
>>Lindsey: So one of the
most authentic ways for me
to help them expand their own vocabulary
is to use my personal experience
with my own emotions in the classroom.
>>Lindsey: Purpose...
>>Student: Purpose for writing...
>>Student: No. That's...
>>Lindsey: When people start talking
about other things while I'm still
giving directions, it feels frustrating
for me and I have to take a breath.
Catch myself and say, it's okay.
I'm going to try again.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: One
of the critical features
of learning is modeling.
We learn by watching others.
In this classroom, we see the teacher
modeling her recognition of her emotions
and also modeling how she deals
with them in productive ways.
And that is the first step
in helping children learn
to manage their own emotions.
>>Lindsey: Big breath in.
Big breath out.
>>Sydney: Like, it's
complicated, so we breathe.
And that's how we-- so when we're ever
going crazy, it helps us calm down.
>>Lindsey: It's based on
real-life information.
Can you make sure your body is sending
a message that you're listening to me?
Because it hurts my heart when you
look the other way when I'm talking.
Thanks, dude. My heart
feels much better now.
>>Lindsey: Naming my own
emotions and modeling
for the students how I can attach
a emotional vocabulary word
to how I'm feeling and then sort
of articulating how I'm processing
that is a really authentic way for them
to sort of pick up that same skillset.
And for them to also see that I,
as their teacher, am a real human
who is having real feelings during
the day, but I'm also doing my best
to handle them in a way that is
safe and kind and productive.
So they recognize that having big
feelings are part of being human,
but being able to name
them and do something
about them is really the work
we're going to do together.